good evening everyone I'm Philip flurry
I have the great privilege of sorry I
faded out many hope that happens Britt
but hopefully not on this occasion so
I'm the associate provost with
responsibility for the Arts here at MIT
and it is a double privilege really to
welcome back all of our Elias and to MIT
he will be here and up here in a moment
to talk with us and he just reminded
himself and me as we were chatting if I
may Olaf earth at this may be your sixth
lecture at MIT over the years so I'd
like to think he's part of our family
and I encourage him to think that of
himself and I'll come to the good reason
why he's part of this family they're at
least a couple of excellent ones so
we're also here to dedicate afterwards
his masterful installation at the MIT
nano our newest building and quite a
magnificent building and you will see
this after this event after his lecture
and it's called Northwest Passage and I
think you'll find it as moving as I do
that's building 12 for you who know the
numbers let me say just a word about the
percent for art program here at MIT it's
the cornerstone of our public art
collection without the percent for art
program we wouldn't have Olaf irelia
'sons art displayed here we wouldn't
have dozens of other remarkable pieces
of work art installations across this
campus so it is just a vital program
that collection contains by the way some
70 works today and it is increasing
maybe not by leaps and bounds it's hard
to do that
but it is growing and it will grow quite
quickly in the next few years I learned
just today the list Visual Arts Center
is responsible
or the percent for art program it is
responsible for the public art
collection and it is Paul ha the
director of the list Visual Arts Center
who leads those efforts for MIT and he
does it so admirably
yes so the percent for art program was
established many decades ago fifty years
ago in fact and it allocates now up to
five hundred thousand dollars for an art
project to be associated with any major
new facility MIT builds or rehabs okay
it has to be significant but it's hard
today to imagine buildings that aren't
at least on this campus as some of you
know all too well the policy as I said
is 50 years old established in 1968 but
there were earlier collaborations
between artists and architects on this
campus before we formalize things last
year - stunning percent for art
commissions were established went up one
is all AFER's and the other is by Nick
Mouse they were completed and added to
our collection and I want to mention and
thank the principle donors to the
Eliason project and just take me a
second MIT itself which provides the
base funding that I just referred to
Robert Sanders class of 64 in Sara Ann
Sanders who have been long longtime
supporters of our public art collection
and this percent for our program
14 demoulas and Tom Cote whom I'm told
are here today and we thank you very
much the David bearment foundation
donors to the 2014 McDermott Award gala
also contributed and the Council for the
Arts at MIT which is the sponsor of the
McDermott award here let me just say a
little about ólafur and it will only be
a little
it's hard to describe him briefly but he
is the individual we're celebrating
today he lives and works in Copenhagen
and in Berlin he has a remarkable studio
in Berlin dozens and dozens of
individuals who work with him at his
studio creating art and doing much more
than that gallery settings there the his
practice and great engages a very broad
sphere through architectural projects
and interventions in civic space he
founded his studio in 1995 and he
expanded and leveraged it to into a
multidisciplinary conceptual and
conceptualizing organization and really
planning the future of what he and his
colleagues wish to create members in
that studio include craftsmen
specialized technicians architects
archivists administrators programmers
art historians and cooks and he makes it
happen with his colleagues and my
colleagues who have visited that studio
come back swooning about the forces of
creativity that they observe in their
brief visits there I said he's no
stranger to MIT in 2014 he was awarded
mi t--'s most prestigious arts award the
Eugene McDermott award in the arts and
he was awarded that for recognition of
his influential art practice and its
broader significance to the public
sphere his visit and residency in 2014
here were an enormous success
appreciated by faculty students staff
and the wider community who had the
privilege of getting to know him and
hear him we were also very taken by his
solar light based project little Sun
it's one of his philanthropies and it is
bringing light literally bringing light
inexpensive light to parts of
sub-saharan Africa and elsewhere
that have no electricity and he spends a
great deal of time in Ethiopia in fact
he teaches at the University and Addis
Ababa and has been there for a while the
McDermott award is now in its 45th year
Eugene McDermott
and his wife Margaret alas both gone
were founders and the first patrons of
mi t--'s public art collection back in
the 1960s today that collection ranks
and I can say this I know I'm at MIT may
not sound modest but it ranks among if
not the top public art collection at a
unit on a university campus in this
country and we are tremendously proud
Paul of that collection which you and
others before you have helped to you
know further and develop and and I hope
you all have a chance to tour sometime
what we do but Oliver it's your show
welcome back your home thank you for
being with us really and congratulations
[Applause]
so thank you so much
Thank You Philip and thank you for
having me back here let's just put this
in my pocket exciting to see so many of
you again last time I was here was
celebratory and I was in fact the great
company of mrs. McDermott who I
understand has passed away since I was
here last so I thought I should start by
sending my blessings to her path good
journey from from here on and and I
remember her daughter was there was I
couldn't hear so well what mrs.
McDermott the older was saying Margaret
what's her name right my god she leaned
over to her daughter and said I like
this guy he's like us and I said what do
you mean by us he puts on his trousers
one leg at a time she says that's true
it's not actually how I necessarily see
myself as you will find out but but it
was sweet that she gave me that memory
and I often used it and in Europe that
doesn't always translate into a very
very very strong punch line but I think
of mrs. McDermott with love and her
daughter gave me in other senses now I
have mom sort of sort of sharing a few
jokes I thought the daughter left me
another one I've used that very often as
well this person is all hat and trousers
and no horse and this of course in
Europe makes no sense at all
but I guess but it's fun to say never
this so I had a great time here with the
McDormand and and and and honest quite
honestly it was a really fantastic
moment so I celebrated you for having
had this long relationship with them and
and and by all means when I started
gymnasium
a seven eighth grade I actually had a
Texas Instrument as I said as I believe
I said that as well so it was very
touching all in all nevertheless so here
I am today to to be with you and as you
just mentioned I've been coming really
for quite some years I've had lovely
relationships some of which have been
ongoing I worked again and again with
Caroline Jones I was here and who - mr.
Bowers here at the Oscar with a rainy
green even before that first small
agitated project I came back on a number
of occasions and the McDermott McDermott
situation and around Lillian was of
course wonderful and incredibly well
hosted by Lila McKinney who I hope they
I love good to see again so so it's been
very exciting obviously when this
opportunity to actually do a work of art
here on campus came I could not be more
happy even though we have been working
on it for seven years which for my
standards is very a long time but I
understand here it is not quite quite
that long and and so that thing with the
trousers and / taking on the Charles and
somehow made sense and in the course of
that I briefly met Vladimir as you have
like oh they haven't changed a bit
over those same seven years so that's
lovely - no sorry I obviously do feel in
fact that I'm you know if not family
then no extended family I was yes I
would say so brought a few of my slides
just to give you provide you some
context and I try to pick a bit of a
work that somewhat resonated with the
with a work that some of us should you
not be too cold afterwards to walk over
and this is something where you have to
be invited to but I suggest you all just
pop over and see it afterwards and then
I think we might actually have a few
questions over there and some hot cocoa
right ok so I can get started yeah Paul
is doing like this so okay I get it
called anyway
[Music]
first slide should we lower the light a
little bit and I obviously I realized I
can walk around was way so I can see it
so one of my very first works included
drizzling a little bit of water from the
ceiling and then having a pretty you
know light on it a spotlight in fact and
as you all know this is actually what I
said last time on my lecture last time
so I hope you bear with me when you look
at a water drop which also has water on
it you see the spectral colors depending
on the anchor right so when the drop is
up here it sort of Lewis down here sort
of red and and so on it's also what
creates a rainbow and all of that and
it's interesting to think about the fact
that they that the the colors obviously
is depending on the triangulation
between the lambda drop and the eye and
if there's no I
one could argue there's obviously also
no color because the angle is not there
and and in that sense it's also
interesting to think that they philip
standing over here and i'm over here the
angle for him is different so he sees a
different rainbow way so even though
we're in the same room we're sharing the
room and we have a collective or shared
experience it is by definition a
different and his own rainbow and one
could even argue that it is not
necessarily the eye that is taking in
the color so that from the light to the
drop to that i one could also as well it
is the life the eye that is looking at
the drop and therefore the colors there
were so one could reverse the subject of
the object or even negotiate whether the
eyes actually a consumer and maybe a key
the eye is in fact a producer of the
rainbow so that's a so a nice concept to
suggest that should you get involved
with out of sort of take upon yourself
to go into a sort of a artistic
situation
let's not define that they find it
further now you might instead of seeing
it as an opportunity for you to take in
or consume or sort of take with you a
dance it's also an opportunity for you
to sort of create or produce or become
the person who actually
co-writes the narrative i mean i would
like as an artist to have a little bit
of the narrative and my side of course
having create
the setup with the drop and all of that
but the nice idea I think is the
hospitality of the generosity in in in
fact allowing people to explore the fact
that they own what it is they see now
it's just a question do people actually
feel that they own it right but I think
it's fair to claim that it always has
hosted the opportunity for you to take
the ownership of the experience and
maybe define the narrative or create the
narrative or to create the situation if
you want that you in fact are producing
the reason why I start by this is
because I think it's an interesting it's
an interesting opportunity as we are in
a situation where a lot of people see
themselves as the end of a line of sort
of information right so information very
often is regarded well there's some sort
of source at the beginning with a lot
sort of let's say Facebook or some kind
of huge network so just like a small
narrative source and you become then the
receiver and the receiver is obviously
the last one at the end and and maybe
also often considered the most passive
one right and of course being the
producer seems to suggest that you being
the one who's receiving not as a
consumer but as producer makes you more
active and suddenly being active means
that you also have well at least some
responsibilities right and this is
interesting because once you suddenly
seem to suggest that we the people who
look at the world are in fact
responsible for what we are seeing that
just changes the narrative of like who
actually they ate and who has the agency
or who has the affordance in terms of
defining well what is my reality how do
I constitute what is real for me and I'm
very much aware of that we have plenty
of situations and people and so on and
so forth who are deprived from the sort
of opportunity to actually say this is
my reality and I own it and I'm gonna do
what I want to do and so on and so forth
but nevertheless the notion of the idea
especially within art that you are in
fact in a situation where you can claim
to be right in what you see I think has
a very strong potential and that means
it also allows you to sort of revisit a
very established nervous evil
like for instance a historical narrative
on what was the history of a certain
situation you can go back and modify
that and change that accordingly right
so this is I think one of the things
that is going on in odd right now you're
rewriting a lot of things that had been
written in stone and it by shifting the
narrative realized it's not quite as
stony as you think it is in fact more
relative and once you actually sort of
start engaging you realize well my
engagement has consequences meaning that
if you start debating things things
loosen up and you can introduce an
alternative narrative and an alternative
reality and so on and so forth right so
this was sort of an idea that I think
that there is a great opportunity in not
just in actual a work of art but also
the way that art offers you the
opportunity to also become a person in
the world of course this is a bigger
topic and something one can talk about a
long time I just want to see if I when I
shift here
it seems they're obviously what I have
on this screen is a apparently a
completely different slide so could we
change so I can see so that I have the
same slides on this as here oh no so so
so this thing about the rainbow water
rainbow easy right I had I had that
rainbow you saw before this one it's a
circle right so you walk in you actually
have to go through the wall so it's not
a lot of waters you get a little wet you
look in and you see if I move around the
rainbow will move with me and you sort
of start a little dance with rainbows
and what one could argue is obviously
the body the moving around the kind of
spatial opportunity that a space then
becomes like a circular space in this
race a circular space like a Roman Forum
if you want so they took this notion of
well how do we move
now maybe I have to be closer if I click
here so we until we sort out how I SWAT
switch the flag because we we obviously
we are obsessed with the fact that
looking at that as it also sounds like
looking is something we do with our eyes
but as you can see here we could also
introduced the notion may be the seeing
is actually not an a sort of a sort of a
okay like a no cool activity may be
seeing it's not just a cognitive act may
be seeing is in fact a physical thing so
if you in this round glass tunnel which
is called your rainbow panorama want to
change the color you walk so that means
your physical activity is what changes
the color
one could say downstairs in this
particular museum in aus I was in Oz in
Denmark downstairs Thursdays at the
Golden Age paintings from from the Dane
in Denmark 1862 1880 famous collection
and there's that idea that the gap
between the base paintings is empty and
the painting is the narrative right and
maybe having gone through this you
realise that it is maybe the sequence
and the spaces between the paintings
just like spaces between words that
actually is what writes the narrative
once you walk through the museum so also
mutuality and the way the chronology and
narratives are presented to us it's
actually the up for grasp once you
introduce the fact that you once you
walk through the exhibition walk through
the museum in fact a co-produce or a
co-writer don't throw out I mean I'm
saying don't you professionals don't
throw out the curator don't take the
science away but do not dismiss dismiss
or the miss diminish your own role in
that sort of experience having said that
this sits on the top of a museum as you
can see it's it is in fact like a kind
of proposal for a rainbow where you can
walk around and so on and so forth but
it is also a lovely opportunity for
finally a letting the kids loose for
instance like the small children
run around be loud and and and in in to
last extent also to examine whether the
grown-ups are gonna be okay with that
and have that whole situation well
there's nothing much that they can ruin
so maybe it's okay
suddenly have some grownups going over
your kids are not behaving then they go
like so what is behaving so that's
interesting right so what's the right
and and now I'm not saying and and I'm
quite serious because obviously we are
looking for the small pockets in our
societies where that debate can actually
take place without people polarizing
each other because very quickly
if this was gonna happen in let's say in
the British Parliament Frye's become an
argument immediately with very tough
match against sort of stuck in our
societies are these tiny small pockets
in public space in their core where we
can actually share the situation
disagree negotiate sometimes agree and
then not and so on and so forth what I'm
trying to get at is that on a very basic
level I'm very curious about the fact
that there are spaces within what we
call the wider cultural sector where we
can actually explore the very simple
things of how do we share an opportunity
I worked with this notion of larger
shared spaces for a while this was one
of the very first time I was lucky to
kind of get more involved with this this
is the Tate Modern in 2000 and what is
that three or four I think three anyway
and and the Turbine Hall which at the
time had the only judgment we introduced
to to add the building was renovated by
had to do a demo on and and it it was
sort of free of free entrance and and
you could argue that that part of the
building that being the sort of entrance
lobby to the museum was both public I
mean both a part of the street outside
and also part of the museum on the
inside of course so in that sense it I
thought was sort of on a hinge between
being either a part of the city or a
part of the museum I think since then
this museum have made it more a part of
a museum for various reasons and and but
the opportunity here for me was to see
it was
experiment could I create a public space
in which what we want to have going on
in the public in fact took took space it
took place so a number of different
things can be said about the piece but
if we are now talking today about you
know how do we share space what is a
public space what does what does it mean
to actually be in a space together and I
acknowledge that people have very
divergent ideas about it and still you
are sort of co-producing it together in
this case I was curious about that
people seem to think that sharing it
amplified the quality of the actual
space I mean normally we in AD and
particularly have this idea of that I
wish I was alone in this museum then it
would be really nice and and obviously
maybe there's a opportunity to sort of
revisit our history's obsession with
aloneness if you think about US history
it's been to a lesser extent
written as if you were ever alone always
alone looking at a painting obvious
reasons because it was a very subjective
so narrative and so on but interestingly
it never really was a big topic in our
history that you are always twenty-five
people in front of Mona Lisa but always
right and and to what extent does that
obviously obviously that influence is
the experience of the Mona Lisa I can
see why not history that's not
necessarily the scientific main chord
but but interestingly I think that the
machines are first an opportunity to
also write scientific or have scientific
scientific focus on the fact that these
spaces are space of shared opportunities
it's very complex I get that but point
point here is that at the at the weather
project I think and and this was before
social media and before the ways things
just are communicated today it was a
lovely opportunity where the idea of the
word of mouth and then the notion of the
physical presence actually became a big
issue the physical presence I sometimes
show Joseph is show a little film which
I don't have with me today where people
are in fact laying on the floor then
there is a mirror in the ceiling and
they're looking for themselves in the
mirror and once they have detected
themselves in the mirror they start to
behave in a way with
this one could argue out of sync with
what is what is the sort of definition
of normality within a sort of cultural
institution right so they start to do
all kinds of things and the point here
is obviously not necessarily what they
do is art or out-of-sync it is that all
the other things that one normally does
is suddenly also being exposed because
suddenly when you walk up and show that
Donald Ott's show on the third floor at
the same time lovely exhibition you
suddenly realize that everybody were not
moving very much so the activities on
the floor also made explicit how little
physical activity we are even though
Donald Jordan spoke about the body the
laser how long is their arm and the
space the architecture that was but it
had little body it had a very little
body in it maybe because the way Donald
was also presenting that history was
very disembodied disregarding or even
though it was actually very physically
and vividly described but it was not
about physical activity some people
might be bashing me for having said that
but but but interestingly also you could
also say that the museum machine and I
say it because I think there's a comment
here also to a public space once people
then up in the tunnel just show started
sitting down on the floor looking at the
tunnel job which is very comfortable
it's a good thing to do when you look at
them just sit on the floor the guard
would come over and say you're not
supposed to sit on the floor this is a
Donald Art Show you can if you want see
them so you can go down to the first
show and and in that said no and it's
just it just presented that there is
there are of course all the time and and
and and constantly rules that are not
verbalized non-existent but they're
always there
of course these rules are too sometimes
sometimes because I don't want to just
simplify too much obviously sometimes
they are practically because they kind
of create a social opportunity for
bringing us closer but they also often
are in fact limitations and take away
the opportunity to explore things and
negotiate things in ways that might in
fact take us further into other
solutions see now these these questions
of public space and and who
and how do we perceive the space is
something that I've been working with on
and off I think it's fair as I said that
when we think about public space it's
clear that there's different traditions
in different parts of the world and the
notion public of course stems from also
different tradition in to what extent
humanistic values you could say in fact
brought into the urban practice and how
that urban practice had been taken on
onto I should say a public domain and
you have different so in London as I
understand it there was in there was in
so I might be a little off here but we
lived like 20 years ago there was like
75 architects working in the public
sector Department of City Planning in
London and today there's two and and one
could call that they sort of shift in
strategy there is to suggest that there
is the kind of public agenda in public
space the handling of public space has
been given over to private sector so the
private sector to the latter extent has
taken over should say the the handling
was whatever was left of public was sold
and a little bit of parks and green
areas in London already
Meucci ologist into sort of more
heritage departments was not really
things that I negotiate like they said
now or passing again I can say but and
obviously America has had that similar
tradition it was never really a big pub
there was never been a strong public
sort of tradition for what is in north
and Scandinavia where I grew up this
other idea of the public space here you
had space which did not belong to
anybody and then of course the white
Americans came killed everybody else
who's had and then they took whatever
state so the idea of privatization and
the idea of the pastors and so on and
this has been a well written history and
of course a few people actually brought
some sophistication into that I don't do
in and the sort of American
phenomenology approach that there is a
very strong sense of a social in a
shared space I'm not saying this is not
the case but the point is here still how
do we maintain a public space in which
we are
in fact able to share things outside of
the private real so when I work with
space I very often generalize a lot by
saying okay so what we have we have a
civic society but the great Civic
Society and the civic society we have
what is that we also got the private
sector and the private sector is
different depending on where we are in
the world but then we have of course
also they so called public sector the
public isn't the government the public
that the park centers or the cemetery
sometimes also in America the
precipitates are often very private also
then of course you have different
sectors they have also in American
amazing philanthropic sector but not
very strong in Europe there's a big one
there as well but philanthropic section
America's very active and so on so so
depending on where we are we have these
resources then of course we have an
interesting one which is called the
cultural sector there's a very
interesting piece the cultural sector is
in fact decentralized it's messy it's
complicated but it hasn't it doesn't
have a sort of authoritarian system
Department the cultural sector let's
just say who is that then well obviously
I think it's that's it but it's a lot
more it's all the sort of the dance the
music oh all the cultural things
literature everything then some of the
museum's the theater the barely houses
all this thing then and there's all the
people that work in that right so for
every one author who writes a book even
though even including the book would not
is published apparently that creates 2.7
jobs so the cultural sector actually
interesting it has more employment than
the car industry if you go into and you
have you know nowadays all this is
measured and so on how much money is
return on value and so on unconscious it
my point here is without diving into
something I'm not really specialized in
is to tell you when the culture sex is
actually a robust
civic society the Machine which employs
tons of people has a huge economy mix
between private fit let's offer get
public money
it's an enormous industry which creates
a lot of stability in society it's just
to suggest I as an artist or us as a
culture to the extent that you are
involved with the culture sector we are
not at the periphery of civic society
where the kind of modern mechanics the
economy and jobs and all of that it's
just at the center and the culture had
the periphery because it's very much at
the center of society and so on and so
forth right this one can talk about but
it's interesting to see into
in a world where polarization is a
powerful populism general survey say
decay of trust like falling apart the
things that if that is what we are
seeing
suddenly we could look for well who is
in fact at who's acting inclusive who is
acting hospitable who are in fact more
listening than being propagandistic
elite talking and if you look through
civic society I would say well that is
the cultural sector but of course
there's more people obviously I today's
first to say the university's
educational success and so on so I can
see that it's complex but you see where
I'm getting at I think the culture
sector has the potential and I don't
meet me necessarily as much as I also do
but you know I I think that if we look
at as the ethic kind of larger structure
of the culture sector we have a lot to
offer we just also need to make it
available and stop being sort of
obsessed with romanticizing our
comfortable position at the periphery
claiming that out here the truth is a we
own we own this space out here we need
to get into the sense and say that we
actually know to offer something to the
center of society may be leaving this
periphery center to narrative or
together might be productive so this is
an old project I did this is actually in
Sweden I did it very places place I also
did in Los Angeles because of course the
City of Austin Los Angeles and all of
that so it's a bit of dye it's
environmentally not die emitting die
comes in a few different colors the
green one as you can see here I only did
the Green River Project I realized later
that this is in fact what Patrick's days
in Chicago or see you sir so in C cargo
of course it just means st. Patrick's
Day except on if it's not simple to
state its a Green River so so and and
and and in in it's a kind of
intervention and in this case in
Stockholm it was not presented as an
artwork so it obviously has a sort of
this idea of uh activists ik things
throwing it into water and running
running away it's funny how doing stuff
like that has changed since I did this
was in I think 2001 and obviously having
had a number of for instance terror
attacks the perception of these last
interventions because it does look you
know toxic it looks brutal right at that
point and maybe we were just at the very
back end of a golden age people looked
up and say my god that's really stunning
it's really beautiful it's like a
watercolor or some sort and so on and
and and obviously some people say oh
this is really horrible and and and and
so on and so forth and and actually the
Swedish paper the next day they were the
police could calm down people say there
was a leak in the heating system of the
government the government is still very
building and I thought was fun to do it
by the column as like government in
Sweden particularly being this sort of a
reality machine of northern Europe and
all of that and then the day after again
they had found out it was in fact an
artist who was trying to do an art
intervention and and all of that as to
an architectural discourse one could
argue also interestingly I think
Stockholm is an amazing city it's like
so beautiful and one of the great things
about the city is of course that it is
it is as you say in Italy speak O Bello
right it is so clean it has no problems
but nothing nothing I mean now sweetness
struggling a bit but all in all it's
like it kind of looks like a museum you
come to Stockholm is like traveling 100
years back nothing so-so
so it looks a little bit like a postcard
so you walk into if you go back to what
I said about the body and about you
being
- plane space and say this is me I am
actually gonna produce the space this is
like walking into a museum the museum
totally owns the narrative right reality
is defined you don't need to think just
come and enjoy it's an interesting idea
and and one could then claim well this
is just a representation it's an
idealized version of the good society
and and so and so forth let's give it to
the Suites they've been very good at it
and I love Sweden so it's there's not
the point here but the point is it's
dangerous to maintain this museum in
which reality becomes totally
non-negotiable and you just becomes like
well disconnected not listen to voices
then obviously what goes are not just
not just in Sweden but in many cities so
if you throw in a bit of green tie in a
river like that what happens is of
course the representation of a beautiful
city disappears you know you could also
argue if you go to Legoland in Denmark I
said because you all were quickly I'm
afraid I said that last time - oh my god
is so boring legal and then legal you
know legal breaks you are great friends
with Lego because they and they empty em
and the Media Lab and egoist and I love
legal minista legal Stockholm okay so
you go to liquor store Caligula's and
you go this is Lego Stockholm and it is
not trying to pretend not to believe you
because there's only this whole let's
just all right and you know what you get
it's legal so there's it's totally
honest you could say I mean now you know
you don't say transparent anymore
nowadays but you can see what you get
are you getting right
oh really go to Stockholm it's trying to
be a city 100 years ago so it's like
it's like fake it's a little unfair but
you know it's like trying to be
something else than it is because it's
like the values are in fact stuck and
this increasing disintegrating form so
the Green River was to show
well how does reality actually lose so
suddenly it was not a representation
there was not a postcard of something a
long time ago it was not a set of values
that was talking to me I think it was in
fact as
in which we can live and breathe and
negotiate and own our own position in
the space see now this is more disk this
is a discourse that it's more about I
think open discourse like how do we
prevent the postcard to take over or the
rendering of our reality to take over
our space and this of course was one of
the topics that I was discussing with
Mayor Bloomberg at the time in Bloomberg
how do you prevent the loss this skyline
and the whole narrative of New York
becoming the commodity well how do you
claim back the fact that spaces that has
depth especially something in we occupy
and we stay in together space is
something in which you need to nurture
the public you need to nurture the
alcohol you need to nurture the form you
need to nurture the sort of place where
people can meet and so on and so forth
and as much as we love New York we also
know that New York like many other
cities has gone through various degrees
of of rather ruthless privatization
which has taken away a lot of
opportunities with regards to what can a
space a CD space actually offer people
and is in a world where we see together
with artificial intelligence and all the
robots and all the things that are going
on where people are probably gonna end
up having a lot more free time
especially the younger one in the room
they're gonna grow up in a situation
where they only have to work 30% of the
week and the rest they don't have
anything to do and that's why it's very
important that a city has room for the
70% where they're not gonna be working
right and not every city like like here
in Boston has a major green necklace rod
running right through where everybody
can do everything and of course there is
the Central Park and there's a bit of
space here and there and so on but but
nevertheless this is how I talked to
Mayor Bloomberg and obviously he came at
it from a different angle very
generously he supported it and went
right behind it and obviously saw the
potential arena reactivating the
periphery of Manhattan which at the time
had still been underdeveloped so so I
understand the complexity of what I'm
saying but nevertheless if we just hold
on to the narrative of the waterfall if
you think about it so I being interested
in nature and there's that lovely
discussion about what spatial
opportunities nature actually offers us
the waterfall is very simple if you look
at a landscape especially a beautiful
one
Iceland so I recommend you all to go and
check that out so there's no trees in
Iceland so that means you look at you
look at the landscape itself besides is
being beautiful it's quite odd that
there's no tree because then I do not
know how Lots is the landscape right
there's no scaling and you wonder is it
gonna take me two hours or two days to
walk to that mountain over there and and
and it was just fascinating because it's
not really about the landscape it is you
are struggling with synchronizing your
body your physical so you're trying to
find out is this or even better if you
go to Greenland
you just look is it is it two days later
two weeks what and and of course as a
child when you come to New York you go
like okay for me it was the same thing
but a waterfall then you realize if
waterfalls very slow it's a big
waterfall far away you first very first
this small water throw sabayon it's very
simple everybody subconsciously know
they somehow and you look oh it's about
two hours the waterfall you can see it
of course you can also just start to
move and you realize how this rock comes
closer this mountain moves over there or
that means it's a small mountain or so
far away so if you actually if you
actually walk seeing with your legs you
are you can take the space and you come
so become spatially productive if you
want if you want so I said that's a
Mayor Bloomberg let's give space back to
Manhattan let's unpause cut it let's not
make it a representation that's not
render the city let's not let the
real-estate language take over the
documentation or the city let's take
this city back to the people let's be
Civic and and create the public and the
for home and Agora and as you know in
the course of the his role as a mayor
Mike actually got more involved with
with in fact the notion of of
recreational spaces and of course within
the framework of of an American city he
had a different way of verbal I think
but quite honestly he became very
committed to to the fact that spaces
infected more public spaces to more
productive space to people of various
backgrounds to be more likely to come up
with a shared sense of space then
having to meet in an orchestra or in a
sort of semi-private or on a different
space so he I think and I have still
maintained a relationship on such
discussions and and and and so on oh
this I won't talk oh did I just make two
jumps here okay okay so this is just a
small place in Copenhagen and it's just
to sort of come at an example of what
I'm talking about so I occasionally get
to work in actual public space with
actual public sector politicians and so
on so forth so this was an attempt to
create a bridge so instead of just
connecting the two sides was to suggest
that the sort of the gap between the
chairs so to speak the bridge itself was
a little handful of public spaces so
it's small like small spaces and then
it's also the entrance to the small
sailboat harbour so the bridge sort of
swings up like weeds here in the upper
right corner sort of swings to the side
but then people can sit there in the
Inner Harbor in Copenhagen and so on and
so forth so I'll just take a sip of the
water how are we doing on time yeah okay
this is an MIT this bottle so clearly
you need like some kind of major is it
like long education to open this oh you
just turn it oh my god that's so funny
I'm still here so so I thought CDC now I
try to present you a few sort of
arguments about the potential of the
culture sector but also the potential of
the shared space of the public space and
and I wanted to say something about the
fact that campuses in universities to
elastic center and for a long time will
consider the connection
and that's why every loan always have
like five or six roots and the notion of
actually creating the sort of outdoor
Parliament's has not been necessarily
fully utilized because the efficiency of
American Universities in competition
particularly the campuses are often
quite amazing the efficiency it has been
a driver because obviously they are
paying a lot of money to go to school
and therefore standing outside the
university and debating with the other
people is not necessarily what people
have been paying for but but but
nevertheless I of course I'm very
excited about the fact that there are so
many other works here on campus and this
notion of the space actually being
worthwhile addressing I think it's
something worth pursuing and therefore I
was quite excited about the the building
when I was invited to consider this and
and when we talked about it I looked at
it and and and besides this being a very
prominent piece of science and and
likely to actually impact our future a
lot as a lot of the other buildings and
the inhale and they what goes on there
will as well but this this being one
narrative and and the notion of new
routes I thought that was interesting
and then this whole idea that there is a
kind of see my unit utilitarian
necessity to be able to go from the
front to the back through this corridor
so the corridor actually it's not you
could call it like very prominent it's
actually a little more practical so I
was quite happy to be in a space where
which both had a function or sort of
almost utilitarian route to it a
functional thing and also had the
prominence of being at the very instance
of this very a particular building at
the time I was a studying so because now
this is already done I believe five or
six or seven years ago when we started
talking about this I was interested in
the fact that in 2007 the Northwest
Passage had for the first time been
sailed without an icebreaker at the same
time
the western part of this south pole had
started the fracturing at a higher rate
and and generally there were there had
been more and more sort of ice floating
around and this we had seen on satellite
photos I was just curious about this so
without any very strong relationship to
the nanotechnology I was just interested
in the fact that climate and and and and
the shape of the planet were in fact
changing and new routes were opening and
and this is how it sort of came about I
had worked with this notion of having
mirrors in the ceilings as you saw it in
the tape so a long time ago already but
I worked with it and this idea that when
you look up and you see a mirror what
you see is of course not the mirror but
what is in the mirror name is the floor
so in a sense you are looking up to
something somewhat similar to a
fractured sky if you want like a sky
broken into pieces and what you see in
this guy is in fact the ground where is
ground you're walking on so one could
say that you can actually see the fact
that you are likely to be in a situation
where you have to jump from one mirror
do you see what I'm saying jump from one
mirror to the next in order to make it
into the courtyard if you want so if
that all that ice melts like Northwest
process and south cold I'm not quite
sure how Boston is by if I'm not wrong
posture that's pretty low because we
have water anyway everywhere so I just
thought the fact that a what the fact
that this could also be stepping-stones
likely to be one of our future scenarios
because I think we are moving from a
scenario where we are going to find out
how to prevent the words are coming and
flooding us to try to find out how do we
sign how do we design to quote Paola
Antonelli from from MoMA who's doing the
design Biennale in Milan Wagner how do
we design a graceful departure for
humankind on earth how do we make really
nice that means no so don't get wet feet
it's a scary narrative I was just at the
event with with her Elin indeed where
Paola Antonelli for the first time in my
life made a presentation of a design and
I was just struck by the way she talked
about how do with this
how do we design the departure of
humankind on planet in the most not
ruining way for the planet how do we get
out of here without ruining for the
people who or for the animals or the
plants on ozone in ten sir
that's pretty intense so anyway so I
thought I'm not trying to be gloomy
suddenly here and this artwork but I was
just it just struck me that only two
weeks ago this was the first time that
that narrative was presented to me as a
serious design discussion so so the
whole notion here is of course that what
we see up in the what we see up in the
mirrors are in fact see my circles this
means that it's a it's a you profile
with LED in it to be frank the yellow
color
as some of you who've been in the
building mitosis is quite similar to the
one in the so-called bacteria free zones
I was just wondering whether that yellow
color is just to tell people now aspect
or does it actually kill bacteria
Wladimir does the color sort of yeah you
realize so it's that's not it's not like
germ killing color anyway so so here as
you can tell is it's a semicircle under
the mirror and it was fun to hear a few
of the students I spoke to they said
that first thought it was actually
circles but what it asks you to have is
of course the fact that even though your
brain would very much like to complete
this image and present to you the
technology of the right circle sitting
out there maybe in a hole in the ceiling
it is in fact only a half circle and and
and once you make a little air for that
you obviously we quickly realized that
you're only looking at half a circle and
and one could propose that it's maybe
the Sun and the heat of the Sun being
one of the reasons for our sort of
melting of the eyes but the other one is
also just simple geometric shape like
the sort of the plates are they show the
eye seeds they are they are somewhat
[Music]
random in shapes and the circles of
course a strong geometric shape and so
on and and as you walk through our
curious to see that there are
reflections from the inside and the
outside events
I stood there for a while and there was
a bicycle coming against me and I was
nice to see the bicycle OOP OOP OOP OOP
oh go through the mirror so and and and
and the bicycle once it approached me
when slowed and looked at me why is this
person looking up and not at me and then
the and the bicycle also looked up I was
actually but I'm just saying it's oh so
it's also nice to see that looking
itself in fact influences influences the
situation see now when we go there
afterwards we can have a few questions
so so I don't think I should say so too
much about it now I yeah i sir let's go
on sorry I keep the time another
building in Iceland just cool that was
very fast
no because I want to go and another
building in Denmark these circles I just
want to be respectful for the time so
even though I could say a bit and then
this is a group of building which I just
want to say a few things a few things
about but as you can see there's a sort
of a language in the various buildings
and and as a knock it's actually trained
person can see I'm not necessarily so
interested in the finite architectural
solutions but more and the potential for
allowing the use of the building of the
basis of the building to actually
negotiate the quality of their own
presence there I don't just mean it from
a logical perspective but also for
simply understanding to what extent a
space or spatial opportunities like here
actually allow us to where to should
should I say be more explorative one
could argue that and this is a bit of a
simplification one could argue that the
traditional so hegemony of a box in
architecture like the central
perspective and they sort of the theme
of Panofsky and the whole history of
classicism has organized our way of
seeing things since the Renaissance see
now there was a lot of history in like
one sentence but has organized our way
of seeing space so that it is
comfortably organized so I realized ok
corner line floor wall lined corner with
air line up there know so I know what's
up and down and left and right but I
can't really tell what's north and south
but it also doesn't really matter in
here but to a large extent I'm actually
ok I don't need to constantly check if
I'm here and this I think for a long
time was considered
productive so we had power house but all
these things all that stuff about timber
reality and constantly having to
renegotiate reality it's just too much
hard work one could also argue from a
space and productive and a more sort of
socially inclusive argument maybe it's
actually healthy to constantly be
reminded that you need to check are we
here is this real is our relationship
synchronize with the times in which we
live or is it actually
called in Sweden some fifty years ago do
you see maybe there is a way to create a
space in which we are constantly
reminded that the space is sort of
reacting to us there's been a number of
different attempts that goes well beyond
sort of phenomenon phenomenology one
could say that the Jane Bennet vibrant
matter offer their opportunity to
suggest that everything is constantly
vibrant so we had the triple o the
ontology or is it the matter ontology I
call them but you know they sort of Tim
Timothy out of out of is that that
Houston also okay helping her ecology
professor there we go Timothy Mortimer
Timothy more news is but this idea that
you are in fact constantly checking up
with strategic stories so some of these
spaces the idea was to see if we could
establish the spatial language in this
case is in collaboration with local
Ethiopian craftsmen all local different
local entities local architects
everything so it's a very last thing but
the whole idea that sharing is a
constant negotiation it's a kind of
parliamentarism that is an architecture
agent right and that is why it has no
vanishing points it has no comfort zones
to the extent of saying ok here you can
relax it is constantly and and asking
for your physical attention let's just
leave it at that
let's go on now because I was just
meeting with with a few architecture
students before and they were like so
smart I thought I should say something
that so so this is say they said Martin
sir from Martins from my studio called
the model model room model table and in
my studio I work very much with with
sort of with my hands these are actually
sort of shadow lines you can see I'm a
great to see the closer to the spotlight
they are smaller because and then they
create this grid a few of you who are
your Valletta me you might know this is
the Aman lines where you shoot a light
photon through a grid than you have
their minds
this you know all about that right so
anyway so if you it's funny like if you
make them lamp move the grid further
away from the lamp shadow moves less and
the grid closer to the lamps moves a lot
right basic algebra right and that means
that if you have a lamp in the center of
a round room you can have this kind of
Amman lines moving or the lines further
from the light moves faster and the
lines closer to the danceBlue slower
means that the shadow seems to be
three-dimensional not because of the
thickness of the line but because they
perceived movements the dimensionality
is driven by temporalities I certainly
in a situation what are the rules and
for space right to give it over to time
and because the Amman lines is a space
is our space feelings in system that
it's based on pentagonal or quasi
crystalline progressions that's a nice
argument so playing around in the studio
always good fun doing silly things I
believe Caroline Jones for sex to be
here almost too silly for you Caroline
you went all in thanks for that well
thank you for joining this one you
remember yeah okay another one so we do
a lot of and this is actually the
context of the University in Berlin so
we do a lot of experimentation Zandi as
you can see the hanging out in circles
has become a thing and now we're just
moving through there and I was just
moving towards the end here so worked a
bit with I worked a bit with the public
space lately within the context of
climate and during the different climate
events and a slightly more active istic
agenda not necessarily in collaboration
with a museum here is Paris during the
famous cop21 in Paris where the Paris
agreement was made and this is just in
London two three four months ago
what is that in December and and and to
make a long story short it's a nice
opportunity to see if the public space
can actually
host an opportunity to get physical
about something which is otherwise
mediated to an extreme extent so that
having physical relationship with it is
almost increasingly difficult so so the
idea is of course that people look at it
and say okay yeah I get that ice read
about in the paper all the time know all
about it and we do know all about it
everybody knows all about everything
right but then you walk up to it and
then you look at the seat okay might
think my god this ice is in fact it's
actually quite beautiful first of all
it's like a stunning and then you put
your hand and I gotta go it's really
cold which is sort of new which is this
interesting the knowledge of the hand
like the knowledge of your presence it's
just different than reading and that the
knowledge the mediated knowledge of
brain and then there's a whole sequence
of events and things you could do and if
you are if you're actually not so
stressed you realize that this sound
this sort of popping is all the small
bubbles in the ice and the progress of
course are under a lot of pressure
because the glacier has been pushing it
down so suddenly here you hear like pop
OH
something just popped and then you look
and then you see all the bubbles and
then you realize oh in these bubbles
there's a twenty thousand year old bit
of air and if you spend a little more
time you realize if you find a pocket
because there that air so-called you
find in your pocket in the eyes you can
actually sniff into the pocket and then
you can smell the air twenty thousand
years ago it's very interesting so you
see our physical senses ears melon
touching and so on so so it is I mean
now of course on the photos it's
spectacular and st. Paul's in the
background in law it's all very exciting
and so but but honestly speaking it is
incredibly physical and for a lot of
people I would also argue an opportunity
to emotionalize a narrative that is
otherwise very data-driven which is
great we need data but we also need to
combine that set with our feelings right
and in that sense I've become more
involved with things that are sort of
about well how do we feel about what we
know well it's not just about you know
turning knowledge into doing or turning
thinking into doing is also about
turning thing into doing and finding out
how do we feel about it at the same time
because having a motion and everything
is more likely to inspire us acting upon
it than just knowing about this is a
project related migrants and refugees it
was in in Venice it's called the green
light project was actually also in
Houston at the at the at the University
in Houston that's a bit unfair that I
can't because rice thank you so much yes
and and and it's been traveling around
it's a workshop format where people buy
the notion of collaboration and shared
learning where the participants in this
case Syrian and Afghan refugees in fact
both teachers and students some
controversy with regards to the fact
that in Venice particular that the
participants were exposed to the visitor
which introduced a complex problem but I
thought this sort of stability of the
cultural sector would allow for the
Civic Forum for actually having the
expulsion not being a sort of alienating
one which in in to some extent I
probably was wrong about but
nevertheless I'm so confident about the
robustness of the cultural sector that
it can take a bit of passing from from
unhappy people especially academically
trained people and so on but
nevertheless it's it's a thing that I've
been very interested in and this brings
me to the last topic because I spoke so
much about last time I want I want by
with it too much this time but but I
have actually here in my pocket
something and before we go well because
this somehow has a little bit to do with
the project or whether as you can see
this is a little object here a small
little lantern in fact and I chested in
Berlin a few weeks ago so this is how
the Sun looks in Berlin and the charging
station is here it's a solar panel
photovoltaic panel and a little a little
rechargeable battery on the inside the
point here is it's obviously within a
sort of a social economic model whether
philanthropic or or market-driven
two to two depending on how we succeed
we're both a foundation and a social
business but the idea is to see if we
could drive energy
sustainable energy into areas where
there's no access to energy and of
course the idea is here that that not
only does that have a major impact
locally but also of course that
understanding what energy does in the
sort of sequence of a life and education
whether you have your store open you
just want to have light in your home
instead of having a fire on the floor in
that sense I think it's a it's an it's a
project that for me has a lot of things
to do with what I learned from the art
world and how I could see if I could
actually utilize rice or almost apply
some of these at these artistic ideas
onto something which is outside of the
comfort zone of the artwork because I've
gradually become increasingly
understanding that the art world is as
much as I talk about the cultural sector
being a very significant part of civic
society the advil is by all means also
often a very latest and closed and
self-obsessed places closed circuit
especially we go into the part of the
art world which is also called the art
market then of course it becomes
incredibly it is but nevertheless this
has been a project for me which I've
been enjoying a lot and obviously one of
the great things I learned was to
actually have spent some time here at
MIT both with with technology and also
the School of Economics and exploring
the different things so and so there's a
lot learning in this that actually came
from MIT during the time that I got to
spend here from the McDormand price and
all of that obviously I could not ask
you to take you and so go and find this
on the home page called ill center come
and then you put on on your social media
and spread it and then people buy more
of them and then we get more money to
drive the lamps into the hands of the
people who are in fact actually happy to
use it just as an ending note because I
normally talk about this as kind of you
know an opportunity to also emotional
eyes and make explicit something which
is very hard to make tangible energy
this this actually also have a quite
significant impact because not having to
buy petroleum for a household which has
limited resources this is of course also
an opportunity to save money which then
could go to something else
and as we are about to pass
the 1 million lamps now being almost 8 7
8 years old has slowly Peck we're not
quite there so little push
it's like with Bernie Sanders little
boost on that there's a million anyway
we are this year I think gonna hit a
million but that just means so if you
think about this saving a family one
dollar a week and now in the best world
if they were all on and so on so that's
like a million dollar week right that's
like 50 million a year and if the
lifespan is five years that's like 50
it's like 250 million which would
otherwise have gone to petroleum juicy
so so it's not just that $1 for the
families the cod crowdsourcing way of
taking 250 million dollar worth of
petroleum out of their car economy of
fossil fuels right so there's a kind of
reversed opportunity in this which has
to do with a very decentralized like
idea and so on and so forth this is of
course a whole talk and and so on by in
it by by itself I just wanted to end it
here because as we're looking at
somewhat solar related and the ice and
melting and so sustainability a question
so and I thought this was a nice thing
to end so I passed the clock a tiny bit
whole are you gonna be taking over after
me so I thank you all for staying put
thank you so much
oloppor for such a powerful and
thoughtful piece and the idea now is to
go with vladimir beloved the director of
MIT nano to building 12 with Olaf er to
experience Northwest Passage thank you
all for coming